my role is as a case handler in the
state aid in energy and environment
my background is an economist i've
always been an anti-trust economist i've
been specializing in
regulation and antitrust particularly in
the network industries in the itc
sectors
as a member of the chief economist team
i
assist the case teams with their
analysis of cases i attend meetings with
parties i help shape the thinking about
the
how to approach a case from economic
theory
generally you have lots of interesting
interactions with people within the
commission
i specialize in competition law and i
was working
for a number of years in different roles
as a competition lawyers both in-house
in private practice and as a regulator i
am a case handler in the antitrust
energy unit
i am an economist i have a phd in
economics
and before coming here i used to work in
the private sector and also in public
administration
you need the ability to communicate to
work well with others you need
the skills to analyze a vast amount of
data
and reach the right conclusions and do
that in a collaborative process
what i'm bringing in terms of expertise
is mainly
quantitative modelling and the ability
to read business plans
and determine certain values
certain indicators for business plan
profitabilities well i
use economics a lot so i need to make to
know about economics and i also
draft a lot and we also participate in
meetings with
external stakeholders i use my skills
and economic theory
and econometrics and empirical skills oh
i love the colleagues it is very nice to
have really
well prepared colleagues i do feel that
obviously the decisions we take here
are very important and it's also great
to see how
big institutions like the commission
works and overall comes to hopefully
sensible decisions
probably the most interesting thing is
having to do
enforcement which is a way for the
commission to have a particularly
significant impact on the economy i
enjoy working
in the most interesting um
high-profile cases that you can have in
europe
and i enjoy working with people who are
on the top of their game
and and making sure that we do the right
thing for europe
it's nice to work on the good side it's
nice to work for the good people
i mostly use english in my work and
occasionally also german and french
mainly english the working language
sometimes
using french and italian which is my
mother tongue